many young workers entering the job
market at an unprecedented time experts
weigh in on what these college graduates
just starting their careers need to do
to learn and advance
the job market today for young workers
presents its own unique challenges many
of the college grads just getting
started in the career fields are working
from home missing out on some key
aspects that an office experience offers
when things were more formalized you go
into an office and you could observe
co-workers and you could sort of learn
by osmosis almost because there's so
many things that college doesn't teach
you unfortunately that you learn once
you get out into the working world
angela copeland is the senior vp of
marketing at recruiter.com she says if
you are starting your career off working
from home you need to create structure
for yourself also foster relationships
with colleagues to learn what's expected
of you and how to do your job
effectively i would start out by really
making sure you have things in place
like a weekly one-on-one with your
manager if you don't have one you should
ask
you know look for things like a
mentorship program at the company if
that exists
and try to also
set up coffee meetings with other
colleagues like create friendships
because you learn the most really from
other people she adds think of your
career as your own business most
importantly make choices within your
career around learning and growth right
now not money ask yourself these
important questions will i get a mentor
out of this boss will they help me
and really look for those kind of
opportunities because later in your
career you'll have time to make more
money but first you've really got to lay
the foundation
great advice from her now she also says
she's seen a lot of college grads opting
to live at home because rent is
expensive and they're working remotely
she says it's very important to keep
family life and work life separated you
want to be perceived as a professional
adult make it clear that you are there
to provide your own expertise christian
well